[Music]
colin kaepernick tweeted on wednesday
it's a three year anniversary the first
time that he protested systemic
oppression that came in the form of
sitting during the national anthem he
would eventually go on to kneel during
the national anthem and he would
eventually go on to be shunned by the
NFL after the 2016 season complicating
the situation the NFL's new partnership
with jay-z and rock nation and Chris
when this was first rolled out on
Tuesday it was kind of a soft launch
where they had a few newspaper articles
and website articles about it it was
officially launched yesterday I thought
something's not right here because jay-z
supported Colin Kaepernick does this
mean Colin Kaepernick's getting back in
what does any of it mean and it became
clear yesterday when jay-z was answering
questions with Commissioner Roger
Goodell he's just glossing over this
whole Kaepernick thing he's focusing on
the future and I think a lot of people
are troubled by it and rightfully so
because to the extent the NFL is now
aware of the message that Kaepernick was
trying to send you can't say you've
gotten the message but still continue to
kill the career of the messenger well
yeah you know it still boils down to the
32 owners who are not gonna want to deal
or the coaches are not gonna deal with
want to deal with the distraction of
having Colin Kaepernick I mean
ultimately even for the coaches who are
totally in his corner about what he's
fighting and all of those things I think
it would still scare them just because
it's gonna become a media circus and of
course you know I know coaches are
creatures of habit they're conservative
by nature as is anyway and they don't
want that type of attention and media
frenzy
I still think hang on how long do you
really think it would be a big deal if
somebody added Colin Kaepernick as a
backup quarterback I mean is it like a
Tim Tebow thing where you're concerned
if he's number two on the depth chart
there's gonna be the Pro Kaepernick
crowd that will never let it go that he
should be the starter is that what your
concern is I think so yeah I do plus
there's a guy in the White House who
might get involved I mean there's just
so many different ways it can go to
where it just will never end and that's
what I think would scare owners and and
coaches ultimately you know as as you
know and I know you're on the same way
for the fight and what Colin
Kaepernick's doing I really AM it it's a
shame he's not in the NFL it's wrong
he's certainly one of the 64 best
quarterbacks on the planet I can say
that much I mean not even bat an eye
with that but now he's been out of the
game for three years - I mean that's hey
I mean I don't know there's all-time
greats that I don't know if I would
trust once they've been out of the game
for three years it's not easy but it's
not his fault it's that's the problem
sometimes you have you have managed to
freeze him out for so long that the mere
fact that you successfully frozen him
out makes it easier to freeze him out
that's what I have a problem with let me
let me point this out before we run out
of time in a segment yeah um I was told
six years ago when jay-z started the Roc
Nation sports agency that this may be
the first step in a play to eventually
become an NFL owner Chris and I'm trying
to read beneath the surface here and see
where this is all heading this is a big
deal here and he can create a lot of
goodwill with the owners by helping them
advance their goals whether it relates
to social justice improving the Super
Bowl halftime all the things he's gonna
be doing I don't know what kind of of
money he has if he can afford to be a
majority owner of an NFL franchise
because I think at this point you at
least need three billion to pull that
off but I think this is the next step
toward jay-z potentially owning an NFL
team
I hear you're there I feel yeah I would
expect that too you know he's he's an
extremely smart individual he's really
kind of encountered it all through
growing up in you know rough areas in
Brooklyn and certainly been around of a
lot of different people of different
cultures and I do think jay-z's heart is
in the right place with this whole thing
I mean I do think he's doing this not
only as a business move but yeah he's
trying to shed some light and some
knowledge on 32 white owners about know
your thought process is wrong or your
tactics are wrong about attacking this
situation and that's where I think you
know - what you're saying he can really
get in the trust tree or the circle of
trust there with the owners and and
maybe be some sort of an owner at some
point 31 white owners one is a Pakistani
who has authored one of the all-time
great success stories the shot constant
sorry
here at 8:16 with like five dollars in
his pocket and building the empire that
he has but but your point is well-taken
I still think it's very very delicate to
try to balance what jay-z is doing now
with his past support of Colin
Kaepernick and the fact that capric is
still frozen out of the NFL
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports